[Music]
so christy if you're
22 or you're 42
and you get really really enthused about
a new thing
it is human nature to want people that
you you're doing something that's
working for you you're winning because
you got
this thing whatever it is and um
then you want other people to win you
want other people to experience the
success that you've had
it is natural to want to tell your
brother to sell his car yeah
to tell your mom and dad to get their
act together you know
our whole family's always been bad with
money and i found a guy who's good with
money no matter if you're 22 or 42.
the problem is people don't care
that you're excited and it's i mean it's
like
uh if you lose a bunch of weight and you
run around telling everybody they have
to do what you did
or you whatever i mean i'm glad you lost
a bunch of weight i lost 37 pounds this
year so
i needed to i got fat during coding and
so
uh but i haven't run around made
everybody else do it you know and now
some people ask how i did it and what i
did and i've shared that with him then
but i didn't go up to him and go i'm
looking at you and i'm thinking you need
to lose some weight
i didn't do that you know that's kind of
unappealing it is
and it's interesting because i think
everybody regardless of your personality
style
is resistant to someone telling them
what to do
on an unsolicited advice someone just
coming up to them saying hey you need to
sell your car regardless of if your
family members
the difference is like you described if
someone shows an
interest hey how'd you do that hey how'd
you pay off all your debt hey how'd you
lose all that
weight when they initiate because
they're interested because they've seen
your example
they are so much more receptive to the
path the plan the principles
then someone just uninvited comes up to
them tells hey you're doing it wrong
here's what you need to do different
the natural inclination is to dig your
heels and go whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
you don't know me it's not your business
you know i missed the part where i asked
regardless of
who you are that's that's a in the human
nature to resist that so how you do it
it matters as much as what you do and so
uh setting that example and letting
people come to you and then being open
to say hey here's what i did
here's what worked for me this can work
for you too yeah and what you can do is
just start
asking some questions uh you can start
telling your story
tell your story and uh you know we can
use the weight loss example we can use
the money example you can go
hey man i just paid off twenty two
thousand dollars in debt
and people are gonna go oh wow that's
kinda cool man
yeah how did you do that yeah and well
you asked
that's right so you don't ask that's
right you know now you're gonna get the
whole the whole thing is to trick them
into asking
there you go tell your story and then
they
invite you into their story well then
you've earned a right to
you've earned a right to be heard and i
think that makes a big difference versus
just going around pointing a finger
casting blame no one responds well to
that
but when you set an example through your
life when you talk about what what's
working for you
you've earned the right to give that
advice because you've actually lived it
hey watch my debt free scream on youtube
you know hey look here that's what i did
man
or you could just go you know i was
really scared
and i didn't know what to do man i got
on this budget
and just being on a plan i feel like i
got a raise
and again all you're doing is telling
your story
and you keep telling your story until
they ask
how'd you do that that's right and if
they never ask you can't say
that's why you should do this too
because you get as soon as you cross
that line
if they if they don't invite you to the
party you are an uninvited guest
at the party that's stinky
that's right nobody likes that that's
rude nobody wants to be the uninvited
guest and so
and it's the the worst is when you try
to do this with your parents because you
have the powdered butt syndrome once
someone has powdered your butt they
don't want your opinion
on money or sex and so i i you know
i i have very accomplished and
successful children
i do not need their opinion unless i ask
that's right but you know my son daniel
ramsey and i were talking about a
business thing the other day he was
showing me this thing he's redoing in
one area of the company
and it was impressive and he wasn't
telling me what i should do
that wouldn't work no right but he was
what he was he was
inviting me and i i did i stepped right
into it
pretty cool how are you doing that and
then he gets to tell me
instead of coming in going we need to
change this around here and you don't
know what you're doing and i'm like hey
dude
you weren't even as gleam in your
mother's eye when i started this thing
so you need to shut up
but instead he uh oh my gosh you know he
you gotta be strategic he did he was
taught by a pro he completely suckered
me in
but that's that's it you tell your story
and that invites people to come in and
and you know that's true
of your faith you want to talk about
your jesus
you're you know that's the most rude
offensive thing in the world it's a bust
up in somebody's face talking about
jesus
and you don't even have to know them and
they don't care what you think about
jesus
instead you start talking about what god
did for you
what was your story that's right this is
what happened to me
i was here and now i'm here i was there
and here i'm in a different place now
and you can you can tell your story all
day and very few people are offended by
you telling your own story
you know i um i answer questions at the
end of the christy wright show
and i got a question i draw questions
out of a fishbowl so i don't know what's
in the what's in the bowl
and several weeks ago i drew a question
out and the question was
why did you choose jesus over other
religions that's how it was worded
whoa and dave i was so caught off guard
because normally it's like how do i
balance it all right like it's like
these practical questions
i was so caught off guard but i just in
that moment just told my testimony and
it was that exact moment of going
i've been invited to share what this is
to me
and what how my life has been
transformed by this jesus
i talk about and because i was asked i
was able to
to share that in a different way but
you're right it's
it's it's setting the example where
people want to ask what's different
about you
what's different about you yeah that's
why when somebody knocks on your door
and forces a book in your face
it doesn't work you know and uh i mean i
saw something the other day on social
media it's like
if one more person gives me the dave
ramsey book i'm gonna kill them
you know that person i appreciate people
buying my books but i kind of agree
yeah you know an unsolicited give me a
diet book
what are you saying you know what's your
point
okay unsolicited give me a dave book
what are you saying you say i'm a doofus
yeah you probably are but you know you
just you just insulted somebody with
yeah
now take back your time book might not
be quite as fast
it might not be quite i always give you
a hard time because when someone gives
someone your book and says you have a
problem when someone gives you one of my
books like business boutique it's like i
believe in you
i need to write a believe in you book
there you go i don't know you got your
brand very on point with what you're
doing here dave
what are you saying the brand's
offensive what are you saying christy
we all know our strengths david we all
know we're streaming i don't know where
we're supposed to be sitting oh my god
that is if you want to convince someone
particularly people you love
we tend the closer we are to them the
the the
tackier we tend to be yeah we violate
even just basic persuasion technique
you know we just go because it's my
brother i can say anything i want
yeah and you you you always talk about
this motivation similar to the topic of
balance but
you know you get asked this all the time
through entrepreneurship how do i
motivate my team and you say you don't
you hire motivated people he even asked
how do i motivate my family you can't
motivate other people you really can't
no but what you can do is put
inspiration in front of them yes
and they may hook their wagon to it yeah
and you my son
are the inspiration yep that's it that's
the deal
so tell your story even if you don't the
story doesn't have to be over
you could be just starting the story but
tell your story don't wag your finger at
them
that's your only shot folks this
is the ramsay show